Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
It is time for a position paper.
This paper does not have the usual visual
fireworks that you see in many of these videos,
however, it addresses the cornerstone of scientific
publication, which is none other than peer
review.
When a research group is done with a project,
they don’t just write up the results and
chuck the paper into a repository, but instead,
they submit it to a scientific venue, for
instance, a journal or a conference.
Then, the venue finds several other researchers
who are willing to go through the work with
a fine-tooth comb.
In the case of double-blind reviews, both
the authors and the reviewers remain anonymous
to each other.
The reviewers now check whether the results
are indeed significant, novel, credible and
reproducible.
If the venue is really good, this process
is very tough and thorough, and this is process
becomes the scientific version of beating
the heck out of someone, but in a constructive
manner.
If the work is able to withstand serious criticism,
and ticks the required boxes, it can proceed
to get published at this venue.
Otherwise, it is rejected.
So what we heard so far is that the research
work is being reviewed, however, scientists
at the Google AI lab raised the issue that
the reviewers themselves should also be reviewed.
Consider the fact that all scientists are
expected to spend a certain percentage of
their time to serve the greater good.
For instance, throughout my PhD studies, I
have reviewed over 30 papers and I am not
even done yet.
These paper reviews take place without compensation.
Let’s call this issue number one for now.
Issue number two is the explosive growth of
the number of submissions over time at the
most prestigious machine learning and computer
vision conferences.
Have a look here.
It is of utmost importance that we create
a review system that is as fair as possible
- after all, thousands of hours spent on research
projects are at stake.
Add these two issues together, and we get
a system where the average quality of the
reviews will almost certainly decrease over
time.
Quoting the authors:
“We believe the key issues here are structural.
Reviewers donate their valuable time and expertise
anonymously as a service to the community
with no compensation or attribution, are increasingly
taxed by a rapidly increasing number of submissions,
and are held to no enforced standards.”
In Two Minute Papers episode number 84, so
more than 200 episodes ago, we discussed the
NeurIPS experiment.
Leave a comment if you’ve been around back
then and you enjoyed Two Minute Papers before
it was cool!
But don’t worry if this is not the case,
this was long ago, so here is a short summary:
a large amount of papers were secretly disseminated
to multiple committees, who would review it
without knowing about each other, and we would
have a look whether they would accept or reject
the same papers.
Re-review papers and see if the results are
the same, if you will.
If we use sophisticated mathematics to create
new scientific methods, why not use mathematics
to evaluate our own processes?
So, after doing that, it was found that at
a given prescribed acceptance ratio, there
was a disagreement for 57% of the papers.
So, is this number good or bad?
Let’s imagine a completely hypothetical
committee that has no idea what they are doing,
and as a review, they basically toss up a
coin and accept or reject the paper based
on the result of the cointoss.
Let’s call them the Coinflip Committee.
The calculations conclude that the Coinflip
Committee would have a disagreement ratio
of about 77%.
So, experts, 57% disagreement, Coinflip Committee,
77% disagreement.
And now, to answer whether this is good or
bad: this is hardly something to be proud
of — the consistency of expert reviewers
is significantly closer to a coinflip than
to a hypothetical perfect review process.
If that is not an indication that we have
to do something about this, I am not sure
what is.
So, in this paper, the authors propose two
important changes to the system to remedy
these issues:
Remedy number one - they propose a rubric,
a 7-point document to evaluate the quality
of the reviews.
Again, not only the papers are reviewed, but
the reviews themselves.
It is similar to the ones used in public schools
to evaluate student performance to make sure
whether the review was objective, consistent
and fair.
Remedy number two - reviewers should be incentivized
and rewarded for their work.
The authors argue that a professional service
should be worthy of professional compensation.
Now, of course, this sounds great, but this
also requires money.
Where should the funds come from?
The paper discusses several options: for instance,
this could be funded through sponsorships,
or, asking for a reasonable fee when submitting
a paper for peer review, and introducing a
new fee structure for science conferences.
This is a short, 5-page paper that is very
easily readable for everyone, raises excellent
points for a very important problem, so needless
to say, I highly recommend that you give it
a read, as always, the link is in the video
description.
I hope this video will help raising more awareness
to this problem.
If we are to create a fair system for evaluating
research papers, we better get this right.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!